انهيار العمله الايرانيه يثير المخاوف من
تبعات كبيره في كافه القطاعات في البلاد
قلقا يتعمق مع احكام التيار المتطرف في
ايران على السياسه الخارجيه لكن ما دور
هذا التيار في الوضع الاقتصادي والملك
ابحث عن الاتفاق النووي والعقوبات هذا
التيار الموازي يعرقل التوصل الى اتفاق مع
الغرب وبالتالي تشديد العقوبات ضغوطات
خارجيه بفعل العقوبات كالحد من الصادرات
النفطيه والوصول الى العملات الاجنبيه
واضطرابات داخليه بسبب الاحتجاجات ثنائيه
تزعج النظام الايراني وتقلقه في ظل عمله
واقتصاد يحتضران
المساله المحدده لقيمه العمله الوطنيه
والعملات وكذلك السياسات والاجراءات التي
اتخذها البنك المركزي لجمهوريه ايران
الاسلاميه حتى الذكرى السنويه الاولى
للحكومه او حتى نهايه سبتمبر اي الى
التاريخ الذي لم تبدا الاضطرابات
والاحتجاجات واعمال الشغب في بلادنا نجح
البنك المركزي في وضع سياساته سواء من حيث
التحويلات او من حيث السوق المشكل وهو سوق
العملات
ركود يضرب الاسواق في العاصمه الايرانيه
تقول تقارير لوسائل الاعلام محليه
والاسباب ليست بعيده العراق ساحه ماليه
واقتصاديه طالما استغلتها ايران لمصالحها
امتثال بغداد لمعايير نظام التحويلات
الدوليه سويفت يصعب من التفاف طيران على
العقوبات الامريكيه